في الأول من يونيو 1980 ، بنى تيد
تورنر CNN بأهداف نبيلة حددها
من قصيدة كتبها إد كيسلر عن
تفاني الشبكة
في العمل بناءً على قناعات المرء بينما
ينتظر
الآخرون لخلق قوة إيجابية في عالم
يكثر فيه المتشائمون
لتقديم المعلومات للناس
عندما  لم يكن متاحًا من قبل
لتقديم أولئك الذين أرادوا خيارًا
للشعب الأمريكي الذي جعل تعطشهم
للفهم في حياة أفضل
هذا المشروع ممكنًا
لصناعة الكابلات التي
تسببت روحها الرائدة في هذه الخطوة العظيمة إلى الأمام في
الاتصالات ولهؤلاء الموظفين في شركة Turner
البث
الذي جمعنا التزامه الكامل
بشركتهم معًا اليوم ، لقد
كرست
القناة الإخبارية
لأمريكا ، كان خطاب شبكة الأخبار الكبلية تيد تيرنر هو أول جزء
من المحتوى شوهد على CNN
منذ 42 عامًا ، ثم بدأ نشرة الأخبار الأولى
من بين الآلاف هنا  كيف بدا ذلك
وبدا عليه في اليوم الأول ،
شكرًا لنيويورك ، مساء الخير
من مركز التجارة العالمي
استعداد تاندبي ثلاثة ، خذ ثلاثة ،
بداية مجانية لشفائي لإبطاء التكبير في شريط لف صغير ،
خذ ثلاثة جاهزة ثلاثة عشر
كاميرا جاهزة بالكامل ثلاثة مركز واحد لأعلى ، مساء الخير ،
أنا ديفيد ووكر وأنا لويس
هارت الآن ، ها هي الأخبار
قد وصل الرئيس كارتر  في فورت واين إنديانا
في زيارة قصيرة مع زعيم الحقوق المدنية
فيرنون الأردن
وكانا خارج لويس وديف كانا أول
مذيعين في CNN في عام 1980 والآن
ينضمون إلينا من سكرامنتو بعد 42
عامًا قمنا بحجزهم كفريق
لأنهم  فريق ، إنهما
زوجان وهما هنا معنا لدخول حقبة جديدة
من cnn ، مرحبًا بكم على حد سواء.
بالنسبة لـ CNN ، هذا رائع ، شكرًا
لك لويس ، لدينا الكثير من طاقة اليوم الأول
هنا اليوم ، ما الذي تتذكره
عن يومك الأول
جيدًا ، يمكنك تسميته بالطاقة التي أطلقنا عليها اسم
الأعصاب ، كيف تشعر ،
لا أعصاب على الإطلاق ، لا أعصاب على الإطلاق ، لكن
cnn  لا أحد  اعتقدت في البداية أنها
كانت شبكة أخبار الدجاج المعكرونة التي
اعتقد الجميع أن تيد تورنر
ستفشل ، فماذا شعرت عندما كنت
تنطلق على الكابل لأول مرة
كما أقول أنك تعلم أنه كان
هناك غرفة تحرير مفتوحة في تلك  أيام وكان لدينا
جميع المديرين التنفيذيين الذين تعرفهم
يتجولون حول
اهتزازاتك التي تعرفها على أعصابهم
ولذا كنا متوترين أيضًا وكان
السؤال الكبير هو ما إذا كنا
سنقول شيئًا بالغ الأهمية حول
الترحيب بالمشاهدين أم لا وفي النهاية لم
يتمكنوا من ذلك  لم نقرر ما نقوله ، لم نتمكن من
تحديد ما نقوله ، لقد قال تيد كل شيء إلى
حد كبير على أي حال ، لذلك
أطلقنا للتو الأخبار ولكن نعم
لقد مررنا بها ، كان هذا هو السؤال الثاني ،
فقط انتقل إلى الأخبار وهذا صحيح ديف
نعم  قم فقط بالأخبار وكانت هذه هي
الفكرة بأكملها ، وكما ذكرنا للتو ،
كان لدى تيد هذه
القطعة الرسمية التي قام بها في الخارج ولذا
قلت لماذا يجب أن
يكون لدينا طبقة أخرى حول ذلك ، دعنا
ننتقل إلى الأخبار فقط هو ما نحن  إعادة كل أبو
لقد فعلنا ذلك بعد 42 عامًا ، هل
أنتما الاثنان الآن يتقاعدان بسعادة ، هل ما زلتم
تشاهدون قناة CNN
طوال الوقت الذي يشاهده الجميع
، هذا هو
الاختلاف على الرغم من أنني اعتدت أن أرسو في
CNN الآن أنا فقط أصرخ في
CNN نعم
الجميع  هل هذا صحيح جدًا ، يمكنك
فقط إرسال بريد إلكتروني إليّ ، سيكون ذلك بمثابة تعليقات رائعة ،
وسنتلقى ملاحظاتك في
أي وقت ، ما هي
الطريقة التي ترى بها كيف تطورت أخبار الكابلات والأخبار المتدفقة الآن
أو تطورت
مثل ما هي انطباعاتك عنها الآن
مقابل  عندما كنت على الهواء
جيدًا ، أعتقد أنه في الأصل كان محتوى إخباريًا إلى حد كبير جدًا ، كان
هناك عدد قليل من
البرامج المسائية التي كان لدينا برامج حوارية ، ولكن
كان الأمر يتعلق بالأخبار فقط وكان هذا هو
الشاغل الرئيسي في ذلك الوقت هو ما إذا كنا
يمكن أن تملأ 24 7 كما اتضح أنه
كان بإمكاننا الحصول على أكثر من أخبار كافية
وأعتقد أنه مع تطور أخبار
الكيبل ودخول المزيد من المنافسة ،
لديك المزيد من الرأي خاصة
في ساعات المساء وأود أن أقول أن هذا هو
الشيء الرئيسي  الاختلاف الآن ولكن ربما
بملكية جديدة قد تعود إلى
تغطية إخبارية أساسية أكثر فقط
[موسيقى]
لك